- I feel like I put like
a glue stick under my arm
or something and it just stained my skin.
("Carmen Overture")
- This is the first time ever
I'm bleaching my armpits.
- I was afraid this might burn,
but it doesn't burn at all.
- (laughs) Oh sh*t.
- It feels sensual.
- Oh yeah.
- No one I knew was excited
that I was doing this,
but I'm doing it anyways.
- My number one purpose
is to make people laugh.
- I'm excited.
If you had told 12 year-old
me that 23 year-old me
was gonna dye my armpit
hairs I'd be like "Whaat?"
- I'm a mom of two kids now.
So I really don't have time
to do grooming anymore,
and I'm really over-shaving.
Knowing that I was
gonna dye my armpit hair
was a great excuse not to shave,
and it let me just, like,
let it loose and free,
and it was really freeing.
- This could be the most
extreme thing I've done.
- I think that those who
matter to me know already
what I'm about and they won't
judge me based upon a decision
that is on the surface.
- When I was 12 and I
wore my first tank top
and I had hairy armpits and people said
"Oh my god, she has hairy armpits."
Look at me and I just, look at
her and I felt uncomfortable.
- I just feel like it's a personal choice,
and it's fine for people
to do things their way.
- I think that women are
starting to break free
and embrace their own standards of beauty
and not let them be
defined by other people.
- Like, wow I see you,
I accept you, it's cool.
("Carmen Overture")
- Here it is!
- To me, it looks like my
armpits got its period.
- Looking like a skin
disease at this point,
but, ya know, maybe if I
showered a couple times
it'll wash off my skin
and stay on my hair.
- (laughs)
- I think I should have
chose a different color.
If i had grew out my hair even longer,
maybe we would have
gotten some better results
- I feel a little giddy about it right now
- I'm probably going to Snapchat my mom
in like five minutes and be
like look what I just did,
aren't you proud? and
she'll be like, "No".
- You surprise yourself
when you do something that
makes you step out of your comfort zone.
- I think this would be a
good bonding experience for
either with my friends,
or me and my sister.
- Do you love your body?
Own it, like, do your thing.
("Carmen Overture")